[Musique]
à bord de leur voiture ces familles
passent d'un monde à l'autre
c'est le seul checkpoint entre les
territoires occupés et ceux contrôler
par les Ukrainiens
ce jour-là la plupart des réfugiés
viennent de Carson
[Applaudissements]
quand les Russes s'emparent de cette
grande ville du Sud au premier jour de
l'invasion les habitants manifestent
très vite la répression commence
aujourd'hui Carson est l'une des villes
où la résistance est la plus active
romane vient de passer en territoire
ukrainien il est amaigri épuisé et
miraculé soldats
ukrainien résistant il était activement
recherché par les troupes russes autour
de Carson
ils sont entrés dans le village avec des
véhicules blindés et ils ont fouillé
partout ils cherchent des armes et ils
recherchait les partisans
leur sniper ont pris position à
l'intérieur du village et ils ont
commencé à nettoyer
dans mon village de ce que j'ai compris
j'ai été trahi quelqu'un dit Horus il y
a un gars là qui dit vouloir défendre
son pays
un patriote aussi qui fabriquait des
cocktails Molotov ensuite ils sont
arrivés
j'ai pu m'enfuir mais celui qui
fabriquait des cocktails Molotov a été
tabassé à coup de cross dans la tête
il a eu des lésions au cerveau
romane se cache dans la forêt il survit
pendant 5 mois grâce à l'aide de paysans
l'armée russe traque sans relâche les
partisans les membres de la Résistance
sur le front sud cette armée de l'ombre
ce corps donne avec l'armée ukrainienne
cette unité composée du crinien de
géorgien et de volontaires étrangers
opère régulièrement derrière les lignes
ennemies
c'est très dangereux de traverser les
lignes ici car il y a beaucoup de mines
de tranchées vous devez trouver un petit
espace où vous pouvez vous faufiler
passez derrière et les frapper le plus
dur c'est de s'exfiltrer de sortir de là
parce qu'à tout moment l'ennemi peut
comprendre que quelqu'un opère derrière
Céline
les informations transmises par les
partisans dit-il sont indispensables à
ces opérations
Amadou
dans les villes où les villages que l'on
essaie de libérer par exemple il y a des
gens qui nous envoient des informations
et ils vivent ici sous nos propres
bombardements aussi car on essaye
d'atteindre des cibles là-bas et eux ils
ne s'en vont pas il reste là il nous
fournissent des informations des
informations très précieuses à propos du
nombre de trous de leur localisation
quel genre d'armes ils ont leur
mouvement on reçoit beaucoup
d'informations de leur part et j'espère
qu'après la guerre ces gens seront
récompensés et qu'ils seront reconnus
par la population ukrainienne
dès le début de la guerre polaire s'est
attelé à organiser la résistance il est
maire d'un ensemble de villages situés
sur le front de Carson 5 sont toujours
occupés
les chemins et qui me rapportaient les
mouvements qu'ils observaient
j'avais des compétences militaires dans
le guidage de frappe donc je rassemblais
l'ensemble des coordonnées et les
données directement à l'artillerie
ce jour là il rend visite à Svetlana
elle fait partie du réseau de résistants
mis en place par ère elle n'a jamais
quitté son village situé sur la ligne de
frontière
le petit jeune qui était là aussi
c'était vraiment quelqu'un de bien je
lui parlais encore ce matin et là
quelqu'un m'a dit qu'il était mort
accepte de parler de leur réseau car ils
estiment que les Russes ne reviendront
plus dans leur ville
les garçons grimper ont des immeubles
avec des jumelles et les observer il
regardait les mouvements des colonnes
russes il les rapportait à l'armée qui
bombardait ensuite maintenant l'armée a
plus de renseignements elle voit mieux
seul ce qui se passe ceci dit très
récemment des gants encore actifs ont
signalait qu'ils avaient repéré une
position importante et j'ai
immédiatement appelé les militaires pour
leur donner cette information
[Musique]
les partisans se concentrent aussi sur
l'élimination des gens qui se sont
tournés vers les Russes et qui n'ont pas
fait que se tourner vers eux on parle de
gens qui ont obtenu des postes au sein
de leur administration
les partisans ont liquidé l'adjoint de
la prison de novakercova
il faut que les traîtres ne se sentent
jamais en sécurité ils aient toujours à
regarder derrière leur épaule et qu'il
s'attendent à ce que viennent les
trouver
dans les villages qu'il administrent
Olère assure que celui personnes ont
rejoint les rendez-vous nous avons leur
nom dit-il et la trahison finit toujours
par ce pays